hey guys and welcome to the game spot
III coop stage at e3 2017 we're here
with a live audience and also some old
friends of ours came and said are
kicking off our show yes we are good to
be back thank you for being the first
guest on the game spot III co-op see
thank you very much if I don't get rid
of us yeah I know never leave early
leave game saw like a badge always like
Oh always bring your eyes contractually
uh you know obliged that's right yeah we
don't talk about that though yeah anyway
what are you having store for our
audience today well so I'm because of
course this is the first time III has
been open to the public public it was a
give us a cheer here you guys are
incredibly lucky
yeah I'm really they turn you away at
the door but this year everyone's
allowed in so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna have a whole load of
challenge except I'll tell people more
so basically we figured now that the the
switches is coming up so strong we're
going to get all of you guys up to try
some challenges in a can visa battle so
basically the way it's going to work is
we've got let's see we're going to kick
things off with Mario Kart 8 deluxe with
some interesting takes on how to do a
race so we'll get to that
yeah we're going to do some split
controller challenges with Zelda breath
of the wild and then we're also going to
have a couple of interesting twists on
arm yeah but all whoa okay so we're
ruining the game know that okay I was my
big secret okay no it's not like
spoilers gave it away thumbs he's out of
practices but yes so we're gonna be
playing arms see this is why we're
having converses have yeah I'm sick and
tired of his negligence
you know just messing things up so we're
gonna be actually picking you guys to
join each of our teams yeah and if
you're watching on YouTube you've course
can like throw your comments in the chat
chastity I will take on the YouTube chat
right now but I also get some volunteers
how many volunteers you need all right
so say well to start off we're gonna do
Mary card so okay I'm icy pool when
we're gonna no we're gonna need yes or
we're gonna need fools your hands yeah
all right okay okay the planners custody
that I'm gonna pick my two favorites
yeah team at SABS gonna do the same so
I'm looking for someone who do you want
uh somebody looks like they'd be good
behind the wheel yeah yes
do we have any rational racing drivers
in the audience Oh Dora
I think uh he's being serious I'll take
my huh
hands back up uh definitely taking you
there pal and I'll tell you as well
buddy
ah come on their famous help you gotta
get in front pal
alright so we'll have him say bond that
says he and then do you want either sit
in front or stand behind it's up to you
okay cool right so just just have a
little round of applause for our
volunteers a special girl singing a ham
here and team SEP whatever so so have
you guys played Mario Cart before a
fight oh I need to give you some sort of
microphone otherwise it's gonna be
really awkward if I do this by lean in
we have a do we have a wireless
microphone two hands I think one's gonna
make its way up all right it's cool well
any time I think you should do a lean in
okay
it was absolutely very quietly whisper
in his ear what do you mean that's a
wound for Las Vegas yet and I've been
playing my cards since Nintendo 64 oh
I've chosen well sad you're going dad no
matter I'm very well I'm Dean I'm what
about team sab this is weird isn't it
my name is Carson let's go with it okay
Carson what I really played Mario Kart
Wii oh I played it a lot okay okay but I
am familiar what seemed like a good pick
all right I'll continue my journey over
here this is fun I'm like a human
microphone all right James I'm James I'm
from New York okay Mario car ever since
game cute
oh yeah tab you're good then and finally
I'm sorry you can't join national Morgan
hi my name is Luke I'm from Pittsburgh
and I could play more cards since I
could walk so ya know what I need I
think I'm gonna hook me up it's gonna be
it's gonna be good okay you can be
player 1 okay my team could be player -
so what we're gonna do is I thought if
we mentioned this yeah but it's it's
split controller so uh one of you gets
to be the left hand side and what gets
the right you as you're sitting down you
can choose a nobody you guys are my
team's you're gonna say one there you go
as well alright it's gonna be an
absolute nightmare I've I've certainly
had oh no no no no you need
- hold it left hand left hand it's a
split controller challenge said I've got
a sudden idea oh yeah let's change the
arrangement on the seats yeah I serve
your team behind what behind well or or
or front well cuz we're gonna be leading
I suppose we're gonna balance things out
right even still they can talk to each
other okay alright if you want to hook
up come up behind you guys want to sit
just side by side yeah this makes much
more sense all right guys okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna come hang with you so if
you're watching hey you wanna hit L&R
you're watching at home when you see if
they're gonna still gonna start and just
have it I think in the name of keeping
things close so I think I'm gonna put my
guys up up front on the floor just to
write you far away from the switch all
right that's fine
you do that so am guys characters yeah
Scott what's your thoughts before we get
to the character selection screen who
are you gonna choose
and what about okay so you guys want to
hit L & R what are you going to choose
guys in it just booties - dude yeah give
it a press honky-tonk yeah I got it it's
a good classic John Donkey Kong he has
okay speed great speed and acceleration
what you really need him in my opinion
you're not worried about his immense
weight and how that doesn't carry you
through the corners well well yes
because that will give us a disadvantage
in terms of drifting but I the speed if
you know how to control him properly
which in this case maybe we should go
with Yoshi or something ah someone's a
control probably we could go with Iggy
Iggy is he's got some good car
selections and he's kind of like you
know got a good drift speed - all right
dad I think you should notice how my
team are already bonding oh yeah they're
already becoming friends I need I need
to keep the aggression with my team okay
how are we doing on the these guys the
sinking of the controllers we're just
thinking the joy cards so I'm do you
guys have a favorite track they always
like to steal my car there we go
I mean I'm gonna go old school and go
with or with the Rainbow Road also
and I feel like my team I need a I need
a bond with my team care of him okay
guys I mean I have my own my own eyes
thoughts on on what character to use and
what like you know what cards sir or
bike sees but what do you guys go for
I've always been a toad person myself oh
yeah nice yeah and how many I mean I'd
go with peach sometimes you meet peach I
actually go with each as well so yeah
good gets all right we can pick this off
we seem to be having a okay so we need
to make sure we keep these uh keep these
connected keep this yeah yeah here we go
I'll just get any synced up back up
again just doing a bit of syncing I
think the the genius idea is making sure
that we're using a Nintendo console next
to the Nintendo booth oh I see where
there's a lot of Troy Khan might be
getting a bit of clash with the giant
Nintendo booth just behind us yeah um
alright guys so each of you this is just
a run-through if you're watching on
YouTube what's going to happen is each
of our teammates is gonna have one
jaikon button only thing their own
character you are embodying the same
character so one of you is gonna be the
left stick steering uh alright let's
pick characters all right let's get this
going so you guys were going for Iggy
I'm gonna sit on the floor as well bond
with my team okay give me a thoughts
trying to figure out who's accelerating
oh he's steering um again we have yeah
we're having right I'm gonna swap seats
with you guys you guys come over here
next to the switch you come and you
perch on this seat together yeah
in fact yeah why don't why don't you why
don't you come and take my seat yeah
yeah yeah there you go
we got it we got to keep it nice and
close so basically I think we need to be
really close to the switch we're just
over there we'll get there this is just
building the excitement of the race yeah
building the excitement so if I can just
do a rough poll of our actual live
audience here who's rooting for team cam
over here give me a cheer no no no no no
no no that's not great and that's
support for team serve guys teams um
yeah come on I was gonna take this I
think it's cuz they know that my team
were the best so you know underdog
alright root for the others get the
character selection alright let's get
this race going
eggie and who's gonna be it's gonna be
tired it's like it's gonna be towed one
of my personal favorites toad always
kids
oh we've unlocked a new car all right so
I think you guys should both use that
that looks awesome yeah definitely so
sad what's your favorite your favorite
car I'm actually a big fan of the bikes
I feel that that top speed is a bit of a
con it's actually it's all about
acceleration acceleration and handling
is always a key to victory when you come
sit back here on this couch buddy I'm
worried you're gonna influence your team
never know that would be cheating so I'm
feeling pretty good these guys have
already been bonding
yeah we've been sharing stories about
their lives the tribe's yeah yes power
they drove exactly and what you're
working about your guys okay well I'm
looking at their selections and be
feeling it and I'm kind of feeling it
though I mean they've gone for they've
gone for the sort of like the fast cart
that looks like speed tires or that I'll
be honest cam they've not gone for my my
style let's just do mushroom cups or
straight in straight into mushroom
castrating mushroom cup first one there
go for it right let's kick this off all
right
okay guys anyone ever tried splitting a
controller on a on switch before
guarantee you it's the best way to play
switch I mean it's much much harder and
this is what we're aiming for here we're
aiming for a really difficult race what
we're going for as well to be clear is
you know not necessarily if these guys
get first place the second place
whichever one beats the other takes the
point that's right imple is out the AI
are there but we don't really care yeah
all right guys at all it's only one race
so let's make it count okay remember to
get the boost you want to press go on
the light so okay a key his team cam and
Taurus - you said come on toad
okay there's a return remote is it all
huh cam I'll be honest I don't fancy my
chances this is going really well
come on eggy so I know it's Harley sure
the the steering controls are on turn is
so I think you want to hold it like that
there we go there we go it was the
orientation so I can went back
right and a cool and a cool night of
course it's only like one of three so
I'm fairly confident so far I'm just
gonna take this mic let you listen to
the team work going on here oh go and
jump okay in the zone sorry hi everybody
hi hi mom in the interest in the zone go
and we go and oh darn
second place still same place like okay
terribly no my I'll see you later Mike
oh come on skulls we're doing very well
said you know what cam the the one thing
that we actually forgot to mention when
we were setting this up is we've got
prizes oh yes oh yeah we got poetry man
people check out on the rigs on the race
have you ever heard of eyes on the road
son yes sir there is prizes now um we
we've actually brought prizes smuggle
the most prizes yeah all the way from
the United Kingdom
we're famous because you see we're
worried over here in America you may not
have tried a real chocolate yeah that's
it I mean it's a big problem for us we
come over here we're hungry for
chocolate and you guys have your
Hershey's and it's just not very good
just not chopped oh yeah we got it
through customs anyone from customs here
no no shut up leave can we get it off we
we get off the stage please
so basically we brought over a couple of
bags of Cadbury's chocolate kbreeze is
the best you've ever had that before we
got loads we've also for the losers
we've got some English tea bags as well
so we brought over some PG Tips it's the
best tea you can buy in the UK I said
I'm pretty sure who's gonna get the
first prize because our guys are the
dole they're legitimately in second they
were winning the actual race yeah but
we're catching up I've made up I made up
two places cam as we're in seventh now
come on team cam you're writing for out
in first so yes very good seventh is
only a small design change away from
first cam
obviously metal mario is being annoying
Zed up front Oh wrong way turn the other
way we've seen me I mean okay I have
dropped to eighth but it is also cool
Meraki
so I think that's a good thing I think I
think it's gonna be first point to team
care I think it might be first one yeah
you're gonna be all right okay
come on Iggy you first come on Iggy come
on again ah ha ha ha yes congratulations
all right of applause
oh hi fine yeah team me wonderful how'd
you guys feel oh we just went with three
two one switch and so we kept saying
that we unify we fuse together very good
I think if I think we've started a
lasting friendship between these guys
James how do you feel I feel incredible
we did excellent well thank you very
much I'm feeling pretty confident I'm
first and first to get on our first I'm
12 wait are we lost
well commiseration hold on guys that was
a good effort where do you think it all
went wrong well for starters I have not
played this game on switch so I have no
idea what the controls are so what
you're saying is it went wrong when I
picked you pretty much yeah how is put
your steering right that's sorry we
could get our steering right here like a
steering huh yeah yeah okay all right
well let's uh let's give these guys a
big round of applause thanks very much
guys nothing prizes for you here
according to me will give you chop any
well we don't run happy it's not yeah
it's really good at you it's not and
just give me back as well
tea bags and chocolates for everybody
it's the British Way all right yeah
thank you very much guys that was great
know how to do good prizes awesome stick
around we're gonna have more games as
well so yeah don't go anywhere I'm
playing a backup uh we won't need more
people don't worry well we'll get them
pigs all right I guess your you are
already chosen friend all right so here
part of team sir by thing okay so we're
gonna change up the style a little bit
for the next game only I thought we're
gonna do the same again okay time to
change up the style I can't be the next
one we got to do the relay okay yeah
this is for all right it's perfect so
well we've her yeah Forrest but why
don't we have you two guys just sitting
down front front here uh-huh oh no no
you guys are good guys to set up it's
cool it's more just uh oh you know what
sit wherever you like yeah our stage
your stage he's live streaming right now
all right hello oh there all right let's
say let's get your names um manse Cory
Cory right on Antonio
Daniel Antonio
Jerald Garrett Ryan and Ryan alright
guys so basically we have a different
style of game this time we're gonna do a
relay every 30 seconds we got two teams
every two 30 seconds you're gonna swap
the controller's pick it up for when
they left off alright get it so doesn't
matter if you don't we're gonna do it
anyway so Seb are they playing split
controller again I don't you can oh
there are sweets they're going them back
together right okay okay we got one
there and if you want to grab the one
behind you as well okay okay so a
different kind of skill really you see
America a deluxe I can just tell you
guys are already too good at this game
so we need to add these extra little
spices to make it challenging
oh I'm alright chastity do we have any
comments from YouTube on that last race
anyone anyone impressed by I City honest
very impressed are you were to go to
Mike yeah we do have some questions
though so question is I would like to
ask what they consider the best co-op
game what do you think Oh best co-op
game see I'm still kind of tempted to
say Skyrim it's not a co-op or you will
be able to play that on switch but it's
yeah no it's not a call game um what do
you mean uh just in general we're gonna
roll that any that's the question that
button Tang asked on Normandy really got
me thinking I've not pleased why don't
why don't we ponder on that way welcome
back this yeah yeah we can enough
silence for 20 minutes while I think yet
it honor it ponder it will come there on
that one okay okay so back to the race
the way it's gonna work is we got to say
is this team cam here this is team cam
cam team said brilliant the way it's
gonna work is you're gonna kick it off
for the first 30 seconds the race after
30 seconds hand the controller over keep
passing it back and forward so there's
just one controller - well one quit one
controller per team right okay so who
wants to go first 14 cam so I'm gonna
get it up Gerald yeah climber up Gerald
okay Guyo
alright so if you guys wanna pick he's
gonna go first so guys what what
character are you thinking oh I'm
usually a Yoshi guy but i'll go with
toph for now okay turn up popular I'm
seeing all right I'm gonna grab this one
I want to get in on the thought process
here what do you what do you think dude
yep yep you don't have to whisper it's
fine
seems like hey here you going for pink
gold peach nothing is cam like picking
out speaking characters in merica a
deluxe bet has a bearing on how they
drive oh yeah of course
so it's I think I think it is a smaller
the character the they're kind of slower
you go with more handling or control you
yeah and the better the acceleration the
big you you are faster you are so
basically if you can pick Bowser and a
fast car you'll have an insane top speed
but if you lose it like getting back up
to that speed again is really hard yeah
but having having the weight on your
side as well you can knock other players
over oh looks like you guys are toward
right so we've got team cameras going
for a rock in a vehicle
what kind of vehicle we got all right
team step going Luigi maybe this
oh the Yoshi bike potentially okay the
teddy buggy that's pretty good actually
my father Teddy but I forget guys you
can get the stats up it's very important
part of the game save you got to equip
your vehicle correctly alright here's
lost you guys want to get get connection
back we're having another connection
issue we are I connect a few L sort
itself at so have you guys played Mario
Cart before what's your experience at
Mario Kart I've been playing since 64
Sinnott I'm 64 okay
yeah so many years of experience any
years this is like part only first year
I haven't gotten any tender product yet
I haven't gotten to switch yet okay so
you're still still holding off i'm still
holding off but very shortly doh very
shortly okay what about you Jared like I
started with like double dash and went
up to like everything after that see ya
you played a lot of mario kart in the
past oh yeah good stuff alright Sam I'm
really confident right team again let's
uh let's get those cards selected and
we'll get the race started
alright so quickly finish come on make
some tires okay we're gonna have to give
it give you a climb little guys just get
them get them selected yep
yep okay elections over and five four
three two one and let's race all right
laughs all right all right should we go
let's go flower Cup um we did last time
let's let's do mushroom Tori yes sorry
yes the thing you said yeah the thing I
said let's do the thing you said flower
Cup join a chunk jumble over to the
flower Cup there we go
and hey des and one more time so what's
your uh what's your favorite track so
far on merica tux
what was the one no I'm not very good
name I was the one where you race the
bikes over the lucite bike side bike at
side by side best one was that in Mario
Kart 8 as well regular I wish whenever I
never unlocks it that far see this is my
first proper America eight experience
ham okay all right guys you ready okay
remember push and go on the second light
all right here we go come on team cab
let's make the night and accelerate
didn't get the boost right okay great
start 14 cam it's a second already let's
get the relay started we a good point
relay timer is that idea so when it hits
30 seconds we're going to get them to
pass the control to the other teammate
no matter what you're doing you could be
myth turning the corner you have to pass
it so you can either use the tilt
control so you can just steer with the
with the sticks as well
both teams doing well are you a you a
tilt control guy you a stick guy are
definitely a stick guys I'm a stick guy
in elastic guy no I will set the tilt
controls worked really well we do but
definitely until all right and swap
controllers for controllers was 30
seconds and team service in the grass
that's where we like to be still up
front very impressed guys I was up I
forget you can give me mix with here as
well you need avoiding that red shell in
the error there and it's over the lap
for the end of lap one where you're ten
seconds till the next swap don't forget
to use your powers is the left trigger
and three two one and swap control
controllers keep it going are we stayed
on the road this time can
I'm feeling very confident I'm really
impressed by my team choice what what
what with me being in Oh up tonight I
mean it's pretty good it's no first so
first set are you in first again how
does this keep happening
I just I'm a wonderful judge of
character oh you got your team's got the
the old bull 8 power up so sell oh we do
high 5 seconds 4 3 2 1 and all right Joe
it was just like watching the Athletics
wonderful real eggs don't forget to use
to stick the steering you get a little
bit more precision that way oh is it and
always the final lap still wear them
first
oh man this is very impressive look at
that power supply sir
Peugeot rolling there are we playing a
defensive game so far cam all right we
got three seconds three two one and
enjoy the ink here we go
final lap my guys are finally on the
final lap here we go I'm not tonight
it's good let's steal that or watch the
Madonna night all right Oh put a billet
bill sir Oh kids I'm not gonna say we
needed it but we really needed ours
cares not for bananas he cares not for
much almost oh come on guys
all right you might a villager hot on
your heels four three two one a sec
control of it over oh it's getting so
close come on guys get the boost job
this job fish come on we're up to fifth
cow we got Billy here no Billy Jase no
catching you cam ah seconds oh I tell
you what though not far behind it for no
far behind thank you very much guys it
was hard luck well done oh well hey
seconds is always the best Oh seconds
always that was really good guys it was
a daisy oh I see well I now hate Daisy
there you go it's well like right well
done so team Sam how did you find that
we were catching up you were catching up
you were doing good for either great
press it what we struggling with searing
and for some reason though the
controller wasn't really working on the
joystick for me well sometimes sometimes
the joystick and the tilt controls can
like fight each other
yeah well no worries you did really well
I mean you pulled it back up from like
last up to fourth so well darn it
yeah don't forget if you if you come it
can be on the stage with us
there is prizes of Britishness chocolate
and British tea because we bring that
good stuff that's how good at this no
you have to provide your own water all
right thank you very much guys can we
get a round of applause for our second
team County SAP well done guys well done
thanks I'm feeling very good about this
to point out up okay good go back grab
yourselves right and we're gonna have
more game stick around when we get back
on stage so Cameron I'm thinking maybe
we got one more game of of America yeah
maybe we can squeeze in two but one more
game again we got a different game style
okay shall I explain you do it alright
so basically we're gonna need four more
players because this time we're gonna do
a slight twist on the on the relay that
we were just doing yeah let's get our
players first
okay let's treat wait so we'll choose
the people before we explain what
they're up for I like it okay could
possibly go okay we need for a full
Merrick our players all right oh yes
you're up okay so you're better said
that uh oh I'm waiting oh no jeez cheese
team cam oh yeah Oh cam okay okay up you
go yeah absolutely
I see how it is I know anyone want to be
on Team said not littering Oh guys what
the po boy sir I America Hat Mario Mario
please come to me come to me and have
one final 14 cam I'll take the the guy
with the shaved head in the beard yeah
but yeah I'm sorry yeah we're like you
maybe you want to be on cam see I'm like
the stairs no no no no you're all my
team whether you like it or not you're
on my team okay so the way it's going to
work guys it's a slight twist yeah I
think the best way to explain this is
we're going to split the controllers
we're going to go four player match
instead of a two player match so you'll
each be playing your own character every
30 seconds you pass the controllers
round so it's a bit of a strategy game
as well being in the lead might not
necessarily mean you win though the aim
of the game is still to finish first but
take for example I imagine you're very
close to the finish line but you're
about to swap controller what do you do
because if you then swap it then they're
gonna win so you need to be careful with
your positioning throughout the race
let's get your name's jasmine you go
jasmine I'm Mike jasmine and Michael
team cam and
my name is Julio Julio Alexis and Alexis
on team said alright guys
oh sorry sorry I'm winning morning honey
I'm not gonna lie I need you to pull it
back ha ha ha I'm on a 2-0 streak right
here so yeah guys have you played Mary
car before
yeah yeah it described your Marek's
tired that I can't even speak describe
your Mary cart experience so far I'm
pretty good I'm okay
I got all three like a great game okay
that delvia
jasmine I mean I have it I've been
playing and I've been playing since the
Super Nintendo
oh yeah jazz without you guys are gonna
be great I'm excited alright keep on my
experience ooh a little bit on the
switch not too much but I'm very
confident very confident open it can't a
long way I've been playing Mario krebons
old - but I made sure to play every
single one because I just love this
series so much and I currently own wire
cardi and I've managed to beat every 212
like and you're wearing a Mario hat so
he's got everything
you're like ever I've already know where
I stand in this team I am Number - yes
absolutely I tell you what a cheap what
would be really good if we can grab two
more of these wrist straps then we've
funny very easier
yeah I've Chaston you think it's gonna
go in such a sea I'm gonna some risks
gonna hook us up so why don't you guys
get comfortable over here find a place
you want to sit if you want to go on the
couch if you wanna know how it's gonna
give enough give me close enough well
let's hope let's certainly hope so
okay alright I'll just I'll perch here
there are you excited about the prospect
of tea and British British treats not at
all
now you're not sure not even at all
uh-uh yeah it's good whatever is what
whatever you said can that sounds great
okay have you ever had British Chuck
sorry have you ever had real chocolate
real chocolate on I have I know from
Switzerland oh I see very good other
than British chocolate yeah okay alright
three eight well cam we're gonna need to
get everyone pretty close together cuz
they're gonna be passing controllers
okay if you guys want to jump on the
floor here now you two guys want to jump
on the floor you know you can stay where
you are
you're good you're good no you stay on
the comfy couch oh sorry so if you have
you guys enjoy the catch and we'll get
the other guys to sit in front of you
yeah okay so let's handsome with troll
emails put that down there I'm gonna
grab one of these you want to grab that
one right there
Oh
okay so the way it's going to work have
a seat something gonna go it's the way
it's going to work is every 30 seconds
I'm gonna get you guys to swap you'll
pass forward you'll pass right you'll
pass back you'll pass left we're all
gonna go in a circle every 30 seconds
yeah yeah so passing in this way
basically the idea is that it's gonna be
chaos but chaos is what we're going yeah
if you're worried that it's chaos don't
be so whoever's the ideal one ah which
is you if you want to hit a and get a or
whatever a looks like great pick so I'm
just let's get it looks very quickly so
I'm gonna give you ten seconds ten nine
seven six
he's strong it is it working a bit
connectivity issues you get you got it
yeah it's a bit ticks mitigate you see
okay we're good what marvelous and very
quickly choose your setup it's gonna
reset the timer and nine eight seven are
you having issues laggy okay um if it
continues to be laggy maybe just really
want to get hit forward a little bit
yeah I'll try and bring the switch as
close as I can that's about the farthest
it'll go so how you feeling about your
chances I'm actually feeling very
confident yeah
the Hat alone is gonna channel some real
racy vibes so say but if you were
playing cuz that would be your tactic
because of course you don't know where
you which character you're gonna be it
will always a race I still think going
going as fast as possible getting an
idea of how many swaps seem to happen
for per lap it's where I'll be going all
right so we're doing star Cup first race
star cup first race I'm looking forward
to this I'm I think there's something
interesting just to be clear we didn't
test this we don't know how this is
gonna work Jasmin's you have any taxi
all the gamble ah I guess if I'm winning
I'm gonna like pull over into the grass
break yeah just before it changes okay
well we'll give you a kit will let you
know when it's five seconds but when
you're about to change so you can decide
how you want to play it alright see
remember you want to accelerate on the
button on the farthest to the right and
you want accelerate on the second light
to get the boost okay here we go
red red green
Go Green the 50 hey how was the test
okay I was going to say who's Who but
there's literally no point in putting it
out this is going to change
all over the place oh okay we've got
you've got a player up in second already
we've got a pretty eclectic mix from top
of the board spanning the whole track
pretty much all right so the first 15
seconds have done down to 10 seconds for
the first one okay
I don't know what to make of this we've
got someone out of first that's very
impressive too one hunk a chain back
keep us forward I think that works and
everyone has to figure out which
character they are now you have to try
and figure out which character you are
whoops
someone's had enough I've had enough
they say I love it I can we've only got
ten seconds till we do that all over
again
oh really is that all maybe maybe we
need a minute sir you reckon up more
minutes give it a minute yeah I'm gonna
give it a minute this one time okay just
sports photo so if you're watching on
YouTube you're trying to figure out what
an earth is going on yeah that's a very
good question
it's basically each person is
controlling one of the characters and
they were passing controllers around
between them but they're still trying to
win so there is some really complicated
tactics of my puny brain and also I see
their complicated tactic tactics like
there's any kind of a strategy I don't
think there is strategy here you think
it's just I think if I think it's pot
luck we're down to five seconds cam
three two one okay swap over trollers
all right shy guys crashing in everyone
way back he's a ghost but still are we
still got our waluigi up in second
counts very impressive really impressive
to me like working together you guys
have got someone at first that's really
good
I feel like the swapping of the
controllers is going to really help
balance the back out yeah I'm gonna go
for 45 seconds Tucson are you just
making this up as you go along
III actually run this so okay I get to
play that game okay we are 15 seconds
all right
so we're still on the bubble I have a
leader we actually have a leader in this
race
so why Luigi is already let's finalize
four three two one
SWAT controllers I'm going back to 30
seconds cam
I want to up the intensity here Jasmine
doesn't know who she is
I think you're the one in 11 right
you've got no sir so you got boots a
mullet will this be but this next one
will be bringing them back to their
original character they will be yes sir
very right you make a sign this is a
real game that's people doing okay so in
five four three two one
I ring you the latter exceptional
character I think Oh Oh big shells oh
you come back just to be blue shell
throw it into the water like this oh man
Oh fourth but you saw it on a fin still
leading the pack though still leaning
the back so when's the next change gonna
be so that's how she gonna be in 10
seconds cam I'm glad you're back ins
yeah get me down to 5 4 3 2 1 swapping
out of it again oh oh we got a finish on
the swamp keep going keep going if
you're racing keep going if someone's
like I've had enough so two two people
have finished two people still racing
all right so I'm like he's losing 12 who
was he got to be controlled with Sam
it's all gone horribly wrong
all right so who came third I mean it
was Metal Mario it was Jasmine is this
is this is everyone agree with the
Jasmine one
so you're holding Metal Mario right now
has been alright generations actually
think you find the team service holding
Metal Mario right now oh really
yeah well this did I had to pass it I
know who that's the game but orbit but
jasmine is is claiming that it was a
past half that after she I don't know
about that oh I had the controller 1372
points and these are points so guys when
you're still a winner to me guys thank
you so much don't forget to take some
tea oh of course
I'm delicious chocolate why wait a
minute Jasmine's not convinced yes this
is British British Joe cam why don't we
let chespin take a fistful of chocolate
it's really good there's such such stars
as their curly wurly yeah it's gonna
hold up the camera
the curly wurly we bring my favorites
nothing but the best a very good
it's very good very much guys thank you
so much then we get to grab some tea and
head over I have a tea bag yeah have a
tea bag yeah you can have two that's
fine Jess where can I grab the package
oh come back thank you so much
thank you very much
he knows he knows oh yeah your about
your backpack oh snap
well done thank you all right boy you're
like I deserve that I think it's time to
switch games I think it is it's on you
see next what's that a switch pun there
Jessie it's very good it's very good I
like to think I'd like to think that was
deliberate ha so next up we're gonna go
with some Legend of Zelda breath the
wild okay we have a game in mind I mean
the game is great in its own because
it's got a lot of cool minigames you can
play
we like to twist things up a little bit
invent our own games we're gonna do that
by splitting the controller again and
having some people on movement and some
people on attack and beef at it all
right how many do you need uh I think we
do is that we will each pick one
teammate but let's do oh yeah time
should we show it in you know explain it
okay yeah I think we'll demo it first
between the two of you yeah okay um but
don't worry all right you asked me a
very good question earlier Jesse I
didn't give you a good response so I've
been thinking about your favorite doing
my favorite co-op experience you know
what it's an old school Bob I think my
favorite all-time co-op experience was
Splinter Cell and which one was it the
one where you it was one before
blacklist what was that one called he
can remind me guys what was the one
before blacklist that one that one run a
business often a score it was one of the
best Kovach spirit see so yeah nice
answer
Oh sad did you have an answer for a
favorite coach where Swami named a lot
of like my my my main co-op experiences
I played all of the Halo games in co-op
and I had the best time of that sighs
I'm gonna say I'm gonna go with that
should I get for you
okay answer was overcooked overlay oh
okay oh but I forgot about overcook yeah
I withdraw mine no it's mine Tina okay
fine I'll go get some volunteers for you
yeah let's have a fun each one he should
be great yeah got it
I'll go look okay you choose
Oh sir bomb we've actually played Zelda
split controller before and we have and
I'd like to say that we're pretty good
at it
we are already handy only in art oh it's
there's absolutely an art especially
with your inverted play see my tactic is
to try and not be the one involved of
doing the tricky bits which is very
flake the combat yeah I like to be the
steerer that way you can't really go
wrong but the blame is mainly on you if
you're a I would say regardless of
whether I'm driving or if I'm fighting
the blame tencel and largely with me
true but so far it's two points to one
yeah oh I'm I'm feeling pretty good good
feel confident yeah so would you like to
steer or would you like to fight in this
demo I'll be fine why don't why don't
you just drive around a little okay
okay so that work the idea is I I can
move us left to right up and down I can
also select our weapons can you actually
do all the attacking yeah my Cheryl's
take that catwalk take that cannon uh uh
highroad so the challenge that I've set
for a FRA players today cam it's
actually just off the edge to the eat
he's messing around now we're never get
I'm listening yeah uh just off the edge
by those cannon we've found a sleeping
hynix
oh one of the bigger bosses in the game
okay have any anyone anyone is here is
anyone played breath the wild yet
yeah I'm cuz I'm feeling like we're
gonna need some rest of the wild players
so this is a complete disaster
I agree so raise your hand if you play
breast of the wild any time even one
time chastity you don't count you get
out of here keep those hands up so we
can see all right so ah Campbell sweet I
love the kind of bag playing a complete
different get me waving yeah me me I got
this alright so I'm gonna grab you right
here you want to jump up mistake no
chest he's already chosen are you chosen
yeah oh I'm so sorry
I'll get you up in a bit don't worry you
stick around there you go anywhere okay
come and jump up so right huh so I'm
gonna go team step right here okay hey
what's your name team can Michael
Michael I don't know why I'm using this
I've got one here welcome Michael I love
you have you here have you played Legend
of Zelda breath of the while before yes
how much have you played not too much
not too much Michael I'm I'm worried
they're worried that's okay so I fix em
do you want to go first team said oh
yeah I mean yeah yeah for sure okay all
right so well explain how this is gonna
work okay first of all can I can I get
to know my guys oh yes because we got to
do some bonding here okay bonding what's
your name
not even Stephen Stephen are you are you
English yes yes I picked the only
English guy at e3 is Deb all right
Stephen so basically the way this is
gonna work is I am gonna drive so I'm
gonna do all the steering and you were
going to do all the attacking okay and
what's your what's your experience level
of breath of the wild not metric I'm by
not very much do you mean none
whatsoever
yeah yeah no more so ever yeah I can I'm
pretty confident amazing
I'm fear this is gonna be great by
confident I also mean I'm losing this on
I know Stephen I think just in the name
of making sure we don't lose our uh or
sad wine an activities why don't we come
and sit up here and I'll come sit with
my teammate over here that's much better
ah okay alright so Stephen the way
that's gonna work is I'm going to work
you want to steer us to the left a
little
okay so I'm going to drop us off here
and there's going to be a Hynix at the
ground and the challenge is who can
destroy it the quickest if we can do it
or if Karen can do it can you get to
time I'm good to time sir okay so should
we do it for the moment we jump off I'm
gonna say yeah we're gonna do it for the
language UMP off I mean you let me know
when you've got when you're ready to
climb I'm ready I'm ready ready okay
okay we're jumping off the edge you
probably want to glide glide now okay
we've lost half my life
that's alright that was a great landing
you nailed the landing okay so if you
want to look up a little just so that we
can see where we're going there he is
there's the hillocks well I saw it okay
you're in binoculars mode making a wind
camp image you might whatever you want
to click stick in get
there you go all right and to attack you
want to use the right trigger and go
alright go on this year oh wait no you
want to use soya but Moe is the right
trigger you sabotage your own team there
with the risk control thing am I'm
winning this fight that's going well
yeah the hillocks you heard him
watch out for that oh I don't know
what's happening I feel like you're an
inverted player on you know all right
I'm gonna revert you I need the I need
all the help I can get can it's okay
this seems like cheating but we let it
it's absolutely not cheating cam that's
the that's the thing
but joke for the eggs it's okay cam
we're gonna win this you've got three
and a quarter hearts left so you know be
colder oh oh power attack very nice
um okay so technically we just died I
think you got struck by lightning we did
this serious wreck and there you have no
weapon save this okay okay we got a
weapon back cam we got our weapon back
oh he's literally saddled you okay we're
gonna win this can I love your winix
he's doing great
oh that's good they're most vulnerable
on the shin that's their weak point come
on keep it talking keep it sagging take
that swing swing man
oh oh it's okay we were sat on but we'll
still be okay alright I'm getting us
into the leg that's good Oh power attack
look at that look we're gonna we're
gonna use the the lightning to our
advantage in ham we're gonna get this
guy get how it works well it passed
through him
I'm gonna say that didn't do anything
whatsoever past room no it's okay little
refine our sword ready to go
oh there it is 30 30 30 can use this as
ogres do it get it get it get it
swing man kill so far your 2 minutes and
12 yes yes yes yes Oh No we're so close
okay we got the power of the fairy
bringing us back to life cam swing swing
swinging oh no we drop the surface it's
still going he's so close to I don't
know honestly don't know what's going on
quick okay random we got a new happen in
this Shin is he's got him he's down stop
stop timing oh yeah Steven you did great
okay thank you
well does be nice we might have given
you a heart attack man we flew him all
the way over from the UK just to kill
him on this stage I'm so sorry that was
that went very very well thanks very
much Sam cam what was our time I don't
so it said your time was a impressive
two minutes 41 seconds point two seven
so let's just round up to two minutes 41
seconds I'm gonna say very minutes 41
seconds is an admirable time to remember
a free mini boss fight do 41
remember yeah okay and I'm gonna check
in actually know what I'm not gonna
check I'm just gonna let you guys like
let's just swap all right okay those are
yours
Steven coma hang with me okay it's gonna
go much better this time so um same
again I'm gonna be the the mover you're
gonna be the combat okay yeah all right
so Steven are you how do you think
they're gonna do um
safety sake okay I guess you reckon
they're gonna beat us probably all right
let's have a little diploid practice so
with attitude
I'm gonna run around oh you're about to
throw the sword you just three just
threw our weapon away might want a key
on weapon we're not gonna do it get too
much practice in here you guys should
pretty much this jump straight off the
edge so I think him he's unit
non-inverting player I think so I just
remind you that I I inverted on our on
our time on our time cam on our time as
true a dead so I'm gonna be knocking off
one minute let's just start time oh no
that's our final time
oops all right I think that's more than
fair okay okay let's pick up the sword
okay okay you ready I'm gonna climb her
I'm gonna start timing are you ready
okay he's ready let's go
all right stop and don't forget to glide
flight man oh yes
never mind it's looking good okay so in
better so to attack you want a this bun
here all right cam not to kick you out
there you go that's the one all right
but you're you're 20 seconds right
listen let's find a headache so I swing
the camera around behind me there we get
there is I see him all right
so yes good to you to just go to me day
together and he'll start doing some real
damage
all right swipe hits that thing okay a
little bit oh don't go very well
all right link get up marring I say you
guys going very well so far
give it get the [ __ ] go go go go now uh
even and I went to it again you gave
just uh again court opinion [ __ ] ah but
if you threw it Adams way to take out
the hit exes if you want to use the the
bow and arrow you can get him in the eye
all right and he'll that's why that one
to his butt okay so did you want to try
shooting with the porn hour so if you
hold the trigger the right trigger yeah
I'd shoot him right in the belly yeah
good job let's go bow and arrow I like
this tactic Oh lovely very close it was
very close to the I go for the I that's
that's not the I that is somewhere else
nother I got that one I all right
between the legs run run run uh well I
didn't work I think we died okay cam
you're at one minute 20 seconds now all
right if you if you stop zooming in I'm
gonna run I've run us away from him all
right so if you leg over there let go
over cut target and let me run with
every missed shot my my enthusiasm grows
go trees there is I see him - left left
left yes
shoot him no ha ha what's this your
other left there go fire yes right in
the that was kind of a crotch shot
that's a low blow
okay up and fire very nice
oh you almost gone in the eye oh you did
ha ha
I would even accept ok gam if you can
make this flight lasts another 45 second
issue you're really great finish him
he's nearly done he's nearly done come
on in the i/o I stopped the timer Oh
two minutes and five seconds cat was
wonderful
well plays oh very good Steven I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry man we flew
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
generally okay far left from it you
choose instruct me that I'll just run
where you say okay we've got one on one
three arrows you want Oh getting there
yeah come on guys working real good one
minute thirty what we've got off a ledge
somewhere take that tree come on one
more one more one more
there we go not the time again one
minute 38 very good yes Oh take that all
right do you think we can beat one
minute 38 I think we can do it for sure
yeah
hi Ronnie I love the confidence from my
teeth this is great I'm good for that
okay guys so let me reload this for you
okay I notice also that you didn't get
the the lightning storm I had to come
out now that's a Seamus I'm not gonna
say that that was a strategic advantage
but you're really bad for you but I lost
though okay thank there you go they're
gonna give you this thank you all right
there you go
so Riley we can critique their their
technique as they go how do you think we
could have done any better or were you
pretty happy with how that went I'm a
little bit happy to have you I should
refresh my memory on the control with it
well I mean how the challenge is
remembering how to do all this stuff
once again I'm hollow I'm gonna grab
this for for timing yeah okay so go for
alright Rahman I I think that's enough
practice there we're just changing
weapons I don't know that's enough
practice oh no no no no no no pull the
trigger for the bow and then I can
change it now I can change arrows yeah
well where is it it's this one yeah this
one there you go choose your arrows all
right we're gonna go ice alright I
sorrows okay oh yeah yeah sorry switch
stance effect go for it all right you
ready yeah
all right so face the right way I guess
wait you're gay and toss start the timer
glide yes glide all right let's go
straight down no bit further let's go
while we go we got some real strategy
here and inflict the pain inflicted a
lie that's very good oh yes take out
those legs
I noticed kami you haven't got the
health bar the hynix up
so I'm not entirely sure you're doing
any damage are you sure myself are you
sure about that yeah the tailor stop the
timer all right man very nice
27 seconds ah nailed it with nail check
what the hell was that
sometimes have you just you just got a
natural innate skill yeah well I don't
know how I'm gonna pull this back you
have won everything back to back bar one
by one by one it's very good
also that guys thank you so much make
sure I get some some tea in some shop
you did well I think there's a real
happy we don't fantast I was good yeah
very good
all right turn your back on the rack
grab a fistful of chocolate and uh yeah
and also don't forget your tea so that
you can have a victory tea later yeah
it's PG tipps it's the finest England
has to offer
well service just about time there for
us to change up to our final game yeah
this actually is particularly exciting
because our final game is not actually
out yet so we're gonna be playing some
arms which releases I think on Friday
well mr. Friday 60s Friday is Friday
then we have a Nintendo booth behind us
we go in and out hey guys is it yeah
they say it is yeah they say it is it's
also playable at Nintendo booth if you
do wanna go play after this so we're
gonna do a couple of arms challenges and
then we're gonna mix things up in a way
that I will explain later
yeah so gonna do some demonstrations for
them oh you don't have very interesting
strategies you're right though I'll get
I'll get the next set set up do you want
to explain what the challenge twists is
the weather twists well yeah we'll just
keep those for now I'll hold on to them
for thank you so what we're gonna do is
a seven I are going to demo how arms
normally works because if you don't
played it jumping straight in to be
quite difficult because it's not a type
of game where you can just flail and win
not really you need to do some tactical
swings yeah how'd it go boxing so as
everyone here heard of arms you know you
know the basic idea behind it yeah yeah
so obviously its motion controlled but
there's so much more to it than just the
just the punching so we are going to
demo how it works we'll get some compact
bit of a competition feeling out here
with some you've done it that you have
done it backwards well then we got a
little
twist on on it later on so yeah come and
check that out this is so complicated
I'm failing at the first hurdle so I'm
gonna get it started
yeah thanks thanks buddy thank you I'll
be in arms there yes we are all right
all right I'm gonna get out of your way
and see if anyone wants to play arms as
well that's great yeah I'm gonna be
playing around pretty harshly maybe we
should wait till we tell them how you're
gonna be playing before oh yeah
volunteer okay that's good right
okay so usually the way it works as she
says you don't explain the concept of
arms all right so the company mom of
arms the video game not not arms the
human anatomy part yeah yeah yeah I got
it I got it okay so basically yeah you
got the controller split like this you
hold them kind of facing forwards with
the little buttons there and you can use
the buttons on the top or on the side to
jump and dash you've also got movement
by tilting you can block by tilting them
in you can punch by punching right and
then you can grab by punching together
yeah that's a grab that's pretty much
the whole the whole setup yeah all right
so much strategy in this groceries yeah
versus you players do it let's go
so sync up come on sync up get close get
close now
time offer them on the switch again I
think that's all the interference from
the Nintendo there they've got to be so
many switches in this vicinity there we
go we got it got it all right we're
ready
all right here we play let's go all
right let's just do a regular flight I
think yeah all right I'm gonna you have
a particular character you like to
players um you know what I'm gonna try
and master mommy okay he's pretty good
I'm gonna go for bite and bark okay
never use fightin bark so great and
pleased with this just writing a random
one as well also all the characters have
different unique abilities so for
example master rummy if I block I'm
gonna gain health yeah so I'm also gonna
stand back so everyone can see the game
behind us Oh shall I step back here as
well there sure yeah better we sky right
so you can also you can select different
arms as well so you don't just have to
use the like the starting ones you can
go for something a little bit unique all
right I am ready I am to see what we end
up with come on all right
I'm actually I'm gonna kneel down yeah
you'll die right see oh I was ready
g-man um too bad all right grab master
mummy you need to really be quite
defensive with no you got your dumb
bleep small and powerful yeah like that
yeah he is that all right for the
guarding the guarding jump left you can
also tell your punches once they're
going forward you can get all them by
twisting the joy Khan in the air come on
come on yes yes come on that's it really
hey I'm not sure what he's a master of
set apparently he's a month master
punching me so uh it's whenever don't
remember where a slight disconnection
issue is your robot dog doing in the
basement smiley no
oh he's punching me oh you better bad
Robo dog gone all that family that's
going I think I understand now I oh
there's so much strategy to this game
ham and I'm not using any of it what are
you having this connection issue sir no
I'm no I'm just having bad games you're
not gonna do this oh come on come on
come on I didn't work at all like
absolutely mess up my special oh I find
Rick three for you thank you very much
okay okay so I think what we want to do
is basically you should choose some arms
for us all right yeah your arms tired
my arms are tired so uh I'm a big
believer in not fighting my own battles
yeah I mean why fight your own battles
when someone else can do it for you
exactly okay so let's find some people
to fight our battles for us so would you
want to choose one person and I'll
choose one person sure okay and uh you
go then
so let's I'll back out okay choose your
foot okay so uh who would like to be one
of my arms yeah you're up you're
definitely up and you want to be one of
my arms as well come on I think you can
get by the fact that I chose two people
that we're gonna get an arm each Oh
oh you picked two I pick two okay this
is gonna be crazy yeah all right I need
two arms who wants to be my left arm
nobody wants to be my left arm yes left
on left arm and he wants to be my right
arm okay great wonderful
okay so yeah we should definitely make
sure we got the gonna play nice and
close okay sure okay so you want to be
left on right on
I think you paid attention like I did
not there you go make sure you want to
be here
there you go save that a little tighten
yeah this is so here yeah so and you're
gonna be left arm you go whichever way
you want it doesn't leave does well you
might want to swap day to be clear
you're on the right way it works yeah
okay so you want to hold it out I want
to be like this left
okay good that uh-huh I'm not gonna
stand here god I gave up buttons power
buttons on the triggers you've got -
you've got jump uh so right okay you've
got a - let me stop jump out there as I
should have done that and then if you
need to block you'll tilt in and you'll
tilt in like that that's blocking and
every time he jumps you can curl round
punko together there grab well arm so
yeah so we need team strategy here guys
team strategy oh we've got a bit of a
issue with connection again there we go
first
Oh No
yeah okay how'd you guys want to sync
your apps up there we're getting again
we're disconnected you might want to be
a bit closer so let's get you guys up a
little closer all right so this is this
is probably gonna be crazy
you guys are embodying my arms so that
means you need to be strong powerful and
win okay good
he's got this he's got this all right so
kami seem to have disconnected as well
are they have they gone all chastity
while we're fixing me these air joy
cones are we having a few questions from
from people watching at YouTube yeah
there's more than one person that wants
to know what you guys think of the VR
version Skyrim oh wow you guys are other
people to ask I'm really keen to play it
yeah um I've not I mean I play Skyrim on
pretty much everything else that exists
I feel like thanks we'll be bringing out
for like the twister like everything
could do skyrim i think vro be really
quite interesting mainly just so I can
cast spells my hands I mean you just
want to do that also they asked what do
you think of the switch version I'm not
well I'm not using it but again with the
trailer did you see with link and the
amiibo I did I mean the idea of dressing
up your character as you know in the
lake costume sounds really good I don't
think oh I like the using of the arrows
with the like pulling the droid come
back I'll it kind of cool okay you know
it was here yeah I'm really on board
with it yeah it's really good yeah I
think that'd be exciting
okay anyways into Skyrim you don't we
can load it in there just want any
amiibo yeah yeah yeah okay to add some
kind of one elevator that's correct
Mannion for your adventure right
schedule alright pick your character
wolves in Skyrim so wink be better son
brand yeah absolutely yeah alright
business good question oh yeah I think
we are are we good
alright good luck thank you very much
welcome alright so the controls are all
you will need to worry about is punching
like this and if you want to you want to
move to one side uses move both your
hands at the same side so left we move
both your hands actually let me just
explain to everybody guys so what you
want to do right if you want to punch
obviously just throw your arm out if you
want to move you can have to move both
of your controllers together to the
correct side
that over here okay and yep like this
and if you want to do your special
that's on the right trigger correct yeah
yes right trigger and then if you engage
that you press same time now your little
bumper that's either gonna be dodge or
jump depending on which control you have
so use those to evade your opponent's
attacks I'm not going to stand here or
all four of you gonna punch me yeah so
all right I'm gonna move right that's
actually the next challenge how much you
can beat cam to pieces in one minute
okay so select the arms you want and
then so player players one which is you
guys you just hit a when you read or hit
L&R sorry there you go
remember you want to want my face avoids
there you go all right here we go there
we go it occurs to me I have no idea who
are my team you are on the right hand
side cam we've actually got these guys
aligned exactly the wrong way around
oh great yeah so I am a ribbon girl yes
you are great come on women girls and
I'm Lynn Jarrah without with a mix of
different arms actually you know you've
gone for the basics so yeah you've got
the rocket arm and that fat the other
one that be able to score but it caught
the peninsula's come power up or they
both boys got home exact you hammer and
a hammer it hammer it
oh good grab we're also getting tons of
screen grabs as well someone's capturing
every single moment of this unmissable
fight 11:07 I think my left arm here is
capturing everything it's really closer
oh no no it's your left arm it's weight
is capturing everything Oh Oh any closer
girl oh yes team step takes a win
well done finally oh yes well done guys
oh another round yeah let's go another
round put change your arms if you want
to I'm gonna sit down here please don't
hit me okay I think I have a good happy
with your arms I believe in you I've got
you godless you got going for the boxing
arms okay come on driven girl
Oh guys you've got your your special
ready straightaway whoa all right ribbon
girl maybe use your special go punch boy
yes that's it that's it ribbon go back
that's not here
that was great combo come on come on
team Zeb I need you guys to believe link
20 forces don't forget to use your arm
you're dodging are you book punch at the
same time you can gap considera grab it
says Muhammad Ali said don't forget to
use your arms the famous quote oh good
effort on the grab there oh it's very
close ribbon girls lowering up yeah the
Special Attack oh yeah
guys well done well well blow my
favorite thing about this game is the
way you can punch your opponent's arms
out of the air so good and you're almost
out of rage at this point you've all got
away lean in a little get a little
closer no no I don't mean physically I
just did no fun to us even closer to my
head at home guys you're almost there Oh
big finish big finish oh yes I have
chosen well cam I am chosen well well
commiserations my team yeah being my
arms I'm much a fine fight both
gentlemen can i let's embrace let's
embrace you don't know what you've done
for me today some big and wonderful
things
thank you you get more tea let me give
you all the chocolate even more tea oh
yeah grab grab and take a fistful lace
yeah they're real good I promise you oh
we smuggle them in from the UK thank you
very much
Oh awesome thank you for taking part
thank you until I went very well
worse I think they weren't very very
well good but and I won't leave you
hanging man I won't leave you hanging
how do you think I went cam that was
crazy yeah yeah I said we have anything
more insane afterlife never I think that
we can see something crazier though oh
yeah I think it'd be crazy if any
minutes 20 minutes okay buddy told you
with the last penny
have your panel all right so I think
we're now gonna what I would say in the
words of like a Microsoft press
conference would be a world premiere
exclusive yeah all right saying that is
definitely DLC in fact we should
definitely not say that it was surely
not DLC yeah but what we are gonna do is
instead of playing like video game arms
we're gonna do a change on it and we're
gonna actually attach the joy cones to
our legs in a game that we're gonna call
legs like how did you come up with a
fine game it's about two hours oh yeah
we eventually came up with this colorful
logo must be real notice I removed the
trademark okay cam speed what are we
gonna play the first match yes yeah we
should demonstrate how legs will explain
how this works okay so very important to
to use the droidcon straps as well don't
want to be kicking oh I'm so gonna bring
it across wait and what am i doing
there you go attaching make sure you get
them the right way around very important
okay oh yeah it's a good point you think
about this this is there we go
trusty could I please have sat scraps
yes yes you may thank you very much okay
there's some straps for you cam thank
you sad another ah thank you very much
this is gonna go let's say it let's
think about this I want to put this like
that
come on do you need me to strap you up
cam no I'm gonna step stop asking me
that I'm kid I don't get it every day
with a question every day always alright
so how you attacking I'm going like this
you see like this yeah side every foot
inside yeah cool there we go all right
I've got one on I'm successfully on this
is the best bit about this mode hey guys
if anyone's heading over to the Nintendo
booth don't tell them we're doing this
there's another and another one I'm
really struggling oh sorry I got it I
got it
yes yeah I got it I'm we'll take it one
more thank you thank you yes okay
marvelous
I I'm actually all set I'm actually not
but I'm getting there okay yeah almost
almost
Oh inside the inside of the boot always
the inside like like this
like this like that all right all right
oh boy
okay so arms with your legs there's
gonna be fun I'm gonna get down on the
floor cause I feel like that's probably
safer good luck
I'm scared chastity okay
all right do I sit on the floor as well
okay get on the floor with me cam all
right
oh here we go let's let's change our
fighter oh so this is uh this boy you're
supposed to play switch if anyone's seen
this all right I'm actually gonna go for
spring man I feel like that's the I'm
gonna go keep the smart choice kit
corbera it's gonna be great all right
and random all right yeah okay so I
match I'm fairly sure I'm holding down
with the strap the select arm button so
I'm gonna get a totally random arm okay
almost certainly I'm ready just go
Cooper yeah go okay now my juice all
right all right here we go
hello going I wasn't ready look the
[ __ ] works yeah Judas grabbing okay
uh-huh
yeah come on
cool I'm winning this fight cap you are
oh hey who hits ah yes
grab grab you Cooper man oh yeah gonna
tempt some dodging dodge dodge dodge oh
my god almost perfect yeah I'm a lot
better arms I am it ladies up with the
legs
stop dabbing with the lip oh my god
all right round two aren't you honking
I'm gonna mix up my arms my legs even
mix up my legs take your feet look oh I
see
oh no it's nice come loose I was see
vigorous your enthusiasm with you three
wait wait wait hold hold hold ever let's
come on
ah all right all right here you [ __ ]
thanks thanks for holding huh yes right
that's right come on yes Khan Superman
use those legs
Oh No did you just activate it so you
can play that game
never I can only if I'm alive yes man
I'm sorry you're weirdly good at this
Oh naked ha ha oh man oh never again
look I'm not saying that's the best game
ever created but that might be the best
game ever created
who would I like to have a cold playing
legs and you guys want to try having a
gag did you not just watch what happened
oh yeah we don't say jet so you gotta
come up come on out ok um do we need
anyone out anybody's not been on stage
once come often play legs yeah great
don't you come buddy all right all right
best game ever
I think we're onto a winner here sev I
can't go short do you want to call
Reggie fils-aime or shall I I'll get
McCall I'll get McCall ok good man so
here we go what's your name column
column nice to meet you man
you're from our father world as well
aren't you I feel like you're from our
part of the world as well you're from
Ireland accounts the eye-rape um Arizona
yep Ramirez Dana what's game Jordan
Jordan all right you feeling confident
good all right Jordan have a seat and no
I'm not hungry they're gonna give you
these all right so and it's this way row
so you want we just always think about
yes well I want Danny from red the
inside of your left here's some water
for looking out to chew is all right I
want to eat what do you think see that
brother left yes I'll strap you up he's
around
oh yeah Lee you really sure yeah
so when did you come over from Ireland
but when did you fly over from old with
Marlon just oh sorry
ah okay did you have any idea that you'd
be sitting on stage about to fight a man
with your legs good I'm glad uh yeah
right I'm gonna say strap your honor
feels reasonably secure they tell me if
this is gonna be painful I think we
might have accidentally started it hey I
think we might have accidentally started
another match we'll find out uh it seems
to have gone as it turned out we turned
it off uh just push the button see what
happens yeah we think we turned it off
somewhere that's impressive
well nicely done very well done us edge
back there we go we're back we're back
we're back right so so yeah push those
two together these to us that's right
here you go you are now you will be way
out in this violence come on you will be
when you win this fight okay I need you
to channel every single Irish stereotype
you ever heard we're late we're good
okay just pamel until it works okay yeah
it's like you're strapping him for a
boxing match look look is it Kenny yeah
okay so here we go the first official
ours was just a proper I was still a
pretend one first official legs match
you kick towards the screen to throw the
punches okay so you might find it easier
on the floor we demand you guys get on
the floor yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna hide
up here on the chair and when you so
just to remind you the controls tilt
your toes in to block tilt your feet
from slide side to move forward and
backwards that does nothing but you can
do that if you want that's just really
good Phil you're richer and then that's
that's punch if you kick your feet
together you do a grab let me know when
you guys like push them forward together
as do a grab okay you ready yeah that's
okay that's it all right camp you want
to do yours oh yeah no he's got it okay
go all right score hey let's go
so sad we've actually swap yet oh man is
there your spring man on the left yeah
ribbon girl on the right so I try tripod
feet together I like here you gone for
the pedal [ __ ] it's just like being
in the gym you this is exactly it these
are these are bicycle crunches cam I
think a [ __ ] we've now not only
converted a new way to play this game oh
oh he's gonna pair up
oh is it Bella back in when I told you
strapping in for boxing matches wear it
I know I know I can't believe I'm up you
all right yo go like this white man you
you've actually got your pair upset oh
yeah if you want to hit your R button
your you can win a powerup mode I'll get
him for you
yours is very just yet oh all right it
was in a block get ground spring then Oh
run it back from the dead well done I
was well fought don't worry it's around
2 under for outing you're doing very
well
how are the ABS pretty good oh you were
doing very well basically if you kick at
the same time you do a grab individual
ones to your left and right if you want
to block tilt your toes together as
pretty much what you need that's pretty
fun you move you move by tilting left
tilting right so till you down this way
till your feet together in a move this
way what stilt them forward okay you
didn't work very hard considering you
didn't know where you were doing it's
very good
all right here we go there you go round
2 legs round 2
okay so I've seen a lot of like bicycle
Fabio so I don't think it's a slightly
in ups as well
Oh spring man you I can see the tango
there we go oh you're doing much better
now that's good see that you can tilt
your your punch by steering it in the
air
oh nice ebook come out again quick again
now when you play it with your arms
there's so much tied to you because you
actually punch your opponent's arm to
the point that I get to be sensitised
you can disable your opponent you can
sort of no leave the air oh no no come
on take the match take the match oh wow
destroyed it one for one now you knew
what you were doing do you want to put
the safety strap on and then we won't
ever happen again so let's do this
a safety strap for a so you do both
suppose to grab at the same time and
under yeah yeah
I'm gonna check doesn't like you're sure
we get you were getting really close
very that was here we go Oh too much too
much
hold on hold on there you go was that me
did I do that I think yeah sorry oh yeah
now we good wicked alright final ranks
run around it when your takes later when
they're taking you will see this
anywhere else at each other guarantee
you that get the punches hammer it
hammer it hammer it I'm gonna come out
again nothing you're still trying to
kick is still victory dress yes alright
skirt righty oh you want more can we got
more strategy going over in my corner I
can see this so obviously the one thing
that particular our guys can't now is
jump or dodge the only controls the
camera gets okay can this is a different
kind of game oh good grab spring man
laughs done it's very close so that's
good I used to call it's very close
bringing us coming right out without
worried so much gets through another one
I was all over oh no oh it's a pretty
decisive victory so I think I think that
round of applause for our gladiators
well done well done that was a big well
done that whispers that's a campus of
working if you didn't get to play arms
with your legs but maybe we can stick
around for one more after this stream
but we're gonna toss it right back to
the demo stage upstairs think you came
to have any last words
oh thank you very much for having us way
to be back against well absolutely man
awesome enjoy the rest you III yes
absolutely thank you
you